bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soit la
mort de claude goasguen figure de
l'assemblée et pilier de la droite
française il était député de paris
depuis 25 ans les suites du cosy l'ont
emporté il laisse un souvenir d'un homme
cultivé drôle entier aussi clivant
qu'attachant l'ancienne école on
reviendra sur son parcours et les
réactions politiques
tout à l'heure enfin libre la phase 2 du
déconfinement annoncé par edouard
philippe va nous permettre de respirer
on n'est pas loin du retour à la normale
la règle des 100 km c'est fini les parcs
et jardins vont rouvrir en ile de france
tout comme les terrasses de restaurants
à partir du 2 juin mais vont-ils
vraiment rouvrir ses bars restaurants
qui sait pour travailler à perte à cause
des règles sanitaires c'est le dilemme
de nombreux chefs on va en parler dans
l'instant avec nos invités on parlera
aussi de cette soif de coupables plus de
70 plaintes ont été déposées contre des
membres du gouvernement pour leur
gestion de la crise peut-on parler de
surenchère judiciaire et même de
populisme pénal on en débattra enfin le
jour d'après nouvel épisode de notre
série d'entretiens ce soir le
réalisateur du bureau des légendes
eric rochant nous parle cinéma après le
corona voilà donc pour le programme et
les riches ce soir à chaque cvr ça n'a
pas changé mon livre
on
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
une phrase une toute petite phrase qui
fait du bien
résume à elle seule l'actualité du jour
la liberté enfin va redevenir la règle
et l'interdiction constituera
l'exception est une réaction qu'on
voulait vous montrez glané à deux pas de
l'assemblée celle de ce jeune homme
après ces annonces a cédé mardi
normalement à barr mois dès mardi du
couchant terrasse avec la roue moi je
savais pas que ça va clairement mardi
matin jusqu'à mardi soir
pour sûr c'est sûr j'adore et voilà on
retrouve enfin le sourire ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas envie de
deux sourires dans le pays on va pouvoir
prendre un verre en terrasse et même
mangé traverser la france respire et
dans les parcs
il était temps bonsoir richard ramos
bonsoir ce qu'elle vous font plaisir
toutes ces annonces
oui elles me font plaisir et là il en
manque encore un petit peu sur les
restaurateurs parisiens et l'intérieur
pour ceux qui le peuvent donc mais elles
me font plaisir c'est c'est le savez
bien que les terrasses et si le partage
et donc des cas du partage moi je pense
que c'est bien pour les français
eh bien on va voir ça peut on va parler
des restaurants ce soir je rappelle que
vous êtes député modem du loiret ancien
critique gastronomique et défenseurs du
bien manger vous allez à dialoguer ce
soir avec stéphane manigold bonsoir mons
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
président du groupe éclore qui possède à
paris quatre restaurants et vous vous
êtes lancé dans une bataille judiciaire
contre votre assureur axa pour ne pas le
nommer vous avez remporté la première
manche
vous allez nous expliquer tout ça
puisqu'on parle des restaurants est ce
que les nouvelles des nouvelles
annoncées sont si bonne que ça c'est la
question qu'on va vous poser dans un
instant mais là bas on va faire le point
sur tout ce qu'on a le droit de faire
désormais avec vous stéphane bonsoir si
j'ai bien compris c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
stéphane enfin libre enfin libre moi je
suis en pleurant j'avoue aussi enfin
voulait la france a changé de couleur
c'était bien compris elle était rouge et
verte puis le 11 mai vient à partir de
mardi et fera orange et verte
alors commençons par les bonnes vagues
qui concerne la zone orange en
l'occurrence c'est surtout
l'ile-de-france opus là et demie yann et
mayotte la bonne nouvelle dont on avait
parlé c'est que les parcs et les jardins
publics vont rouvrir à l'hidalgo est
contente les parisiens aussi voilà
quatre ans mardi ce sera dès ce week end
et a toujours en selle en orange à la
réouverture des restaurants qui est
prévu des bars aussi mais attention en
terrasse ceux qui n'ont pas le terra pad
vont rester fermés à moi que ils
atteignent de l'amérique d'autorisation
d'occuper à un petit trottoir
autre bonne nouvelle la réouverture donc
dès mardi des monuments des musées donc
tout reste l alarme de trion ce musée
jours et tout ça avec un mass
obligatoire pour les visiter laissons
pas de théâtre les salles de spectacles
vont elles aussi réouvrir mai en zone
orange faudra attendre trois semaines
pour cet appareil tous les cinémas qui
vont ouvrir dans trois semaines et ça
dans toute la france
cité des choses un peu moins salée très
importante
la réouverture des écoles alors en zone
orange les collèges qui était servi vont
rouvrir en accueillant deux niveaux 6e
5e les lycées aussi vont rouvrir en
priorité les lycées professionnels
pour ce qui est des lycées disons
généraux y aura plus d entretiens avec
les élèves pour voir où ils en sont à
noter que l'oral du bac français a été
supprimée ce sera le contrôle continu
tout en se donnant dans toute la france
alors avant de passer au département en
zone verte et les plus vernis
rappelons que la possibilité de se
déplacer au delà de 5 vient d'être
établie donc tous ceux qui sont en zone
orange pourrait filer normalement
directement mais attention le premier
ministre a dissout et j'en appelle à la
responsabilité de chacun vous pouvez
vous déplacer vous pouvez aller en
congés annuels mais dans toute la mesure
du possible
si vous pouvez différer un déplacement
lointain c'est probablement plus
raisonnable alors ce qui ne peut
dépasser ceux qui sont déjà entre une
perte alors eux aussi ont droit à la
réouverture des bars ou des restaurants
mais même pas besoin d'avoir deux
terrasses la même des salles pourront
rouvrir simplement pas une personne le
pense et puis pour les bars premier
ministre a dit qu'on n'avait pas le
droit de se concevoir ça il va falloir
qu'on attend les spectacles et salles de
théâtre bon réouvrir andreu ne verra pas
la peine d'attendre trois semaines les
campings ou s'ils vont rouvrir donc
c'est un peu le bildu de la saison
estivale
quant au collège qui était déjà ou après
les classes de 6e et 5e ils vont ouvrir
pour 4e et 3e
il dit c'est bon et avec un seul niveau
qu'on a choisi d'élire soit les sous
groupes soient les premiers soirs et les
terminales qui est bon je l'espère vont
être à peu près goodspeed je rappelle
que le premier ministre a plaidé pour le
maintien du télétravail myriam oui hélas
nous de nous retrouver en studio
c'est vraiment dommage parce que vous
étiez difficilement audible ce soir va
falloir des confiné votre votre ligne
votre ligne et webcam
désolé à auxerre téléspectateurs parce
que on a compris
1 les bonnes nouvelles mais parfois
c'était c'était un peu compliqué
stéphane manigold vous avez quatre
restaurants on va venir tout de suite
sur les terrasses racontez-nous votre
situation pour vous ce sont des bonnes
nouvelles vous allait rouvrir dans l'es4
la réponse en fait en france elle est
plurielle et il y à des établissements
qui permettent cette distanciation
physique et donc cela faut les ouvrir à
paris c'est plus compliqué il ya
plusieurs réponses locales nous n'avons
pas d'élément c'est à dire notamment la
climatisation vous savez que dans nos
cuisines il fait très chaud les chaleurs
arrivent qu il ya des préconisations en
matière de santé travail qui disent
qu'au delà de 34 degrés et bien la
sécurité physique du salarié et sur sa
santé est engagé donc nous avons encore
de nombreuses questions
on suspend et pour se faire une idée
concrète vous avez vous avez un
restaurant pour en citer un la maison
rostand combien de couverts combien de
coups verre en terrasse et au final avec
ses ces conditions de sécurité sanitaire
combien de table vous savez déjà
on savait très simple nous avons 40
couverts la base on va devoir verser 1 /
2 égard à la distanciation physique donc
on va passer à 20 couverts et nous
n'avons pas de terrasse donc on devrait
pas nous vous devez la pale de chiens
ben on voit ce que si on ouvre ses pour
fermer et de faire une procédure
collective devant le tribunal de
commerce est malheureux il y aura
beaucoup d'entreprises qui seront dans
ce cas de figure il ya un prix
sanitaires aujourd'hui pour les
restaurateurs qui vont tenter la
rouverture qui peuvent encore le fait je
crois que si on calcule bien aujourd'hui
nos marges ne permettent pas de diviser
et d'ailleurs aucun business model au
monde ne prévoit de diviser par deux son
chiffre d'affaires puisque nous on a des
collaborateurs qui sont face à un
chiffre d'affaires mais une question
peut-être que monsieur le député va
pouvoir nous répondre et qui est central
notamment en matière de licenciement
vous avez nous avons tous obtenus un an
par la direccte de chômage partiel et
1600 heures par salarié
ça c'était obtenu par la dir est assez
les mesures de soutien de l'état on va
faire c'est un an
et si cette disposition est garanti
alors nous on va adapter la masse
salariale on va laisser certains
collaborateurs au chômage partiel et on
va faire venir seulement 16 ont besoin
les gars à la moitié des clients qui
vint moment d'établissement et à ce
moment là il n'y aura pas licenciement
en revanche si nous n'avons pas ce
maintien de droits alors malheureusement
il y aura des licenciements massifs mais
extrêmement massif de plus de 30 à 40%
des effectifs qui seront malheureusement
se payer aux nouvelles aux nouvelles
contraintes sanitaires je vais vous
montrer une image et vous allez réagir
juste après richard ramos vous
connaissez parfaitement ce ce bistrot
restaurant s'agit du bourbon place du
palais bourbon à côté de l'assemblée où
vont déjeuner dîner boire un verre les
les députés game terrasse ya une
terrasse on va voir justement combien de
personnes en moins vont pouvoir venir
aux courbes ou son gérant son patron
plutôt s'en explique au micro de l amour
d'un gala dans les départements
ils font l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière seuls les terrasses des
cafés et des bars et des restaurants
pourront ouvrir au 2 juin
on est quand même contents annoncé c'est
bien ça fera une ouverture avec
transition on l'a bien vu avec des beaux
jours des têtes autant je pense que
c'est important qu'on puisse le faire
travailler nos terrasses en temps normal
on est sûr sur quarante personnes donc
je pense que là
on va partir sur une vingtaine
on verra bien peut-être que tu avais la
mairie de paris on peut on peut espérer
la d'avoir une extension de terrasses
ici on peut rajouter danger quoi qu'il
en soit il ya les passants donc après il
faut voir comment on gère les passants
sur notre sueur ont intrigué mais on
privatise au bout de trottoir
ça nous permet de mettre en place la
distanciation social et d'avoir d'avoir
le même nombre de places assises
éventuellement faut préciser une chose
il ya 130 places 1 au bourbon à
l'intérieur des murs les 40 places
incluse de la terreur
aujourd'hui ses 20 places on travaille à
perte en fait dans ces conditions-là la
toussaint il y aura beaucoup de
restaurants malheureusement qui pourront
pas le faire
laon au bourbon on est on est une
famille qui a qui étaient là les parents
étaient déjà là je les salue et donc il
ya des conditions qui peuvent permettre
de le faire deux parce que
historiquement mais des jeunes
restaurateurs qui aujourd'hui par
exemple ont investi dans un fonds de
commerce c'est pas jouable et donc il ya
déjà un des faillites et vous expliquer
que les restaurateurs des vidals survécu
aux deux mois mais non je salue jean
louis jamal président de l'umih du
loiret jean louis 74 74 ans depuis 13
ans dans la cuisine il avait il devait
vendre son restaurant dix jours avant le
confinement
il vient de se mettre à la barre du
tribunal de commerce
je dire il est en pleurs jean-louis y
ait beaucoup donc circulent sur cette
évidence ceux qui ne peuvent pas rouvrir
entre 25% et 40% dit philippe et de chez
best c'était dans le parisien récemment
entre ceux qui ont fait faillite et ce
qu'ils ne prendront pas au fond ce
risque de travailler à perte de perdre
de l'argent en rouvrant juste un petit
bout de terrain il y avait il y avait
également des choses qui sont monsieur
l'a dit option peut pas généraliser
par exemple quand à la campagne chez
nous il y avait des restaurateurs qui
ont vite été agile et qu'on fait des
plats à emporter
il n'avait pas de concurrence dans nos
villages de plats à emporter d'octroi
comme en avaient ils ont pas le droit
mais moi je veux dire je vais vous dire
il malheureusement oui mais je vous dit
m
on l'a fait et j'ai dit et j'ai dit au
préfet ils peuvent dire que richard
ramos leur a dit de le faire parce qu'il
ya un moment donné vous savez
il ya quand on est au bord de la mort et
du précipice il faut fait il faut faire
on verra on verra après comme on dit je
veux faire votre combat peut-être pour
parler je vais vous faire une confidence
j'ai yves camdeborde au téléphone et on
attend des réponses politiques rapides
le restaurateur en parler du bourbon on
a besoin des trottoirs
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas si on va pour
utiliser pour toi est en réalité on va
faire ce que vous venez de dire nous on
va les prendre c'est trop tôt à paris
alors à la question oui mais il faut que
dans toutes les maisons arrêter les
arrêtés municipaux qui nous permet de le
faire l'idée fait quoi c'est de passer
des tables et des chaises sur les places
sur les terres en france vous avez deux
choses en fait
vous avez des trottoirs qui permettent
de nous on a déjà cette autorisation est
devant c'est trop tard vous avez des
emplacements de voiture eh bien nous ce
qu'on propose c'est qu'on nous donne
tout le trottoir et qu'on supprime ces
emplacements de voiture et que ces
emplacements de voitures deviennent le
trottoir donc ça nous donne plus d
espace et ça nous permet de survivre
juste un mot quand je disais l'arrêté du
14 mars ne permet pas de créer une
activité de restauration et de vente à
emporter que dit l'arrêté du 14 mars il
dit de poursuivre une activité de vente
à emporter hors du justement dans mon
procès c'est ce qu'a souligné le
magistrat
il a dit parce qu axa indiqué qu'il
avait qu'à faire de la vente à emporter
pour pour essayer de voile à inclure nos
téléspectateurs qu'ils comprennent bien
ce qui se passe on se dit au fond garde
tel manque à gagner que les assureurs
pourraient compenser qu'est ce qui s'est
passé au niveau des assureurs avant de
nous raconter pourquoi vous avez
poursuivi le vôtre
les asurans ont été les grands absents
et dès le départ dès le départ ils ont
mis dans la tête de tout le monde y
compris de nos élus qu' il n'y avait pas
c'est un risque systémique
line assurabilité est la preuve puisque
a été mis au vote à l'assemblée
nationale un amendement 38 le 20 mars
et que disait cet amendement il
permettait d'étendre la catastrophe
naturelle à la catastrophe sanitaire et
ça a été rejetée et lorsque j'ai lu les
débats parlementaires alors votre groupe
c'est plutôt été favorables 1 et chiens
le salut est donc j'ai pas de sujets là
dessus on est content jeudi le modem
quand je lis ce que marie greven ou
rapporteurs la république en marche a
fait elle dit défavorable les assureurs
refusent généralement de prendre en
charge les risques dont l'importance ou
la complexité la ronde non-assurables
parce que susceptible d'engendrer des
dommages d'une ampleur incalculable
pouvons mettre en péril le système
économique même de l'assurance bex et
des avenues de moyens puisque je suis
sûr qu'elle vous écoutez m'arriver je
lui ai envoyé un email
je lui envoie un e-mail pour qu'elle me
donne les docus les ont créés stabilité
du dj slater à ne pas de contraintes des
assureurs à jouer le jeu c'est
sincèrement est-ce que c'est exactement
ces arguments que j'ai retrouvé
justement dans ma procédure
axa a exactement utiliser ses arguments
moi ça me choque donc donc maintenant
vous êtes passé par la case justice
c'est ça l'idée oui parce que on s'est
sentis nous restaurateurs abandonnés par
l'état je tiens juste à souligner il ya
trois hommes politiques qui nous ont
soutenus il ya jean marie bockel
sénateur qui a tout fait un courrier à
bruno le maire paul le sensibiliser sur
le sujet des assurances qui avait des
garanties qu étaient mobilisables
ensuite c'est le le maire du xviie
geoffroy boulard qui a écrit au préfet
pour demander si l'arrêté du 14 mars
était bien un pouvoir de police du
ministre et qu'il avait bien supporté
politique c'était bien arrêtée de
préfecture nous avons jamais de réponse
et dernier c'était bruno le maire où
j'ai eu son son téléphone ça dit-il et
je lui ai envoyé assez régulièrement
quelques messages aux usa et ils
réagissaient dès le lendemain d'ailleurs
celle du président de la république
emmanuel macron aux assureurs bien
actuellement il ya un appel à peine
assez coercitive je suis content riant
c'est à l'aise puisque là on parle des
parisiens mois en province on a on a
mobilisé les préfet avec lui ni avec les
restaurateurs pour faire en sorte que
les assureurs 138 milliards d'euros je
crois de dans la cagnotte viennent aider
les restaurateurs
moi vous savez je le dis souvent des
lobbyistes ont gagné sur le politique
c'est à dire je dis encore une fois que
les puissants ces gens qui se
rencontrent dans des palais qui sont pas
les nôtres
eh bien ils ont fait pression pour pas
payer et aujourd'hui dans ce que vivent
les assureurs sont la honte et
économique de cette catastrophe
sanitaire
ils ont pas été alors que
nous on a eu des inondations dans nos
villages moi ya quelques années il y
avait trois mètres d'eau au milieu de
mon village et bien les assureurs on
était sur une catastrophe naturelle
ça les a pas mis à plat que trouver des
solutions pour que les restaurateurs
pour que ce qu'avait fait tout bêtement
une perte d'exploitation ça s'appelle
comme ça soit remboursé que
l'imprévisibilité des pandémies en
matière d'assurance ça va changer parce
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas le
président du tribunal de commerce de
paris
c'est c'est un argument fantaisiste ce
que à utiliser madame la députée pour
rejeté cet argument il est fantaisiste
c'est ce que le président est du reste
pourquoi cette décision du tribunal de
commerce moi je suis fier de la justice
et l égalité donc en première instance
mais clooney mais peuple français je
vous invite à lire ce que la toute la
documentation fabuleuse du dalloz sur
cette décision de justice je vous invite
à la lire verrez qu'elle est
chirurgicale mais pourquoi c'est une
grande décision parce qu'elle a traversé
le monde entier
le monde entier a pris connaissance de
cette décision du tribunal de commerce
de paris
new york le new york times a fait un
article en chine
yahoo en chine a fait une pleine page
sur cet article en grèce j'ai été
contacté par l'un des plus gros
restaurateurs qui m'a demandé en russie
en afrique du sud au canada
partout dans le monde donc vous allez
perdre jurisprudence et il va les avoir
mais parce que ces morts que dans le
monde en maintenant peau des ateliers
resteront fermées et dans le monde
entier les assureurs ont dit il ya
allard d'assurance post je suis sûr que
raphaël legendre qui est journaliste
économique et qui nous attend derrière
son écran depuis depuis le sud de la
france
écoute attentivement nos échanges vous
êtes journaliste au point je rappelle et
chroniqueur dans cette émission
vous voulez réagir sur les assurances
avant de nous donner quelques chiffres
peut-être sur le court économique dans
la restauration
raphaël à ça ne marche pas bon bah on va
continuer ce soir c'est compliqué un
lait l'ailier de beckham donc donc ça on
a compris le message sur sur les
assurances je voulais revenir sur la
question de ce prêt garanti par l'état
parce que ça c'est la nuit l'autre volet
pour aider on
d'amours les mesures de soutien avec le
chômage partiel mais il ya les loyers à
payer tout le monde n'est pas
propriétaire de ses murs quand on est
quand on est restaurateur ce prêt
garanti par l'état ça marche ou ça
marche pas si pardon globalement aussi
le prêt garanti par l'état moi tous les
restaurateurs 95 % des restaurateurs
sont contents de l'avoir eue et ça
fonctionne très très bien donc il permet
comme ça le grand gosier avec son baiia
et les banques là pour le coup ont joué
le jeu
chez moi le crédit agricole le crédit
mutuel je les cite parce que c'est pour
une fois j'ai envie de dire
la caisse d'epargne ils ont joué le jeu
donc ça ça ça va bien mais ça ne
remplacera pas le fait de recréer une
économie et un business model qui tient
la route et donc de passer ces trois
mois là j'ai envie de dire dont tac je
pense que là pour le coup
l'état a été au rendez vous mais pour le
reste les loyers par exemple quand vous
avez hélas je le dis à tous les
bailleurs publics
quand des restaurateurs parce que il ya
lille ça et ça existe sur les
territoires fait quelque chose
par contre je pense vraiment très
clairement qu'on peut pas obliger les
bailleurs privés à faire cadeau des
trois mois parce que des fois c'est
quelqu'un qui a été lui-même commerçants
et c'est son petit complément de
retraite et donc il faut trouver un
système sur les loyers qui fait qu'ils
vous qu'ils vont faire en sorte que les
loups et le restaurateur ne paiera pas
le loyer et que liées par exemple je le
dis parce que si l'annulation et
guerrier la brévenne je parlais déjà
l'annulation par le propriétaire du
loyer pour et sur le même montant être
une exonération fiscale pour ce même
propriétaire et dans charge par l'état
part et à bonne idée et donc je pense
que il faut que les loyers ne soient pas
payés mais attention à pas dire
attention villa propriétaire parce que
pour le coup c'est de temps en temps des
commerçants qui était leur petit bas de
laine pour leur propre retraite
stéphane manigold il ya des chefs
aujourd'hui multi-étoilé hélène darroze
pour ne pas la citer qu'elle fait
récemment la une de paris match piège
jean françois piège qui vous expliquent
pour fait qu'ils sont au bord de la
banqueroute qui vous disent et c'est
vraiment triste
je suis endetté jusqu'au cou et on s'est
vraiment d'être jusqu'au cou faut savoir
que la crise
cette crise économique elle va elle va
tuer beaucoup d'emplois
trois mois d'inactivité vous l'avez
parlez vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il
ya un prêt garanti par l'état mais c'est
pas de l'argent qu'on nous a donné un
moment faut le rembourser dans un an
et bien quand tout va repartir serve
qu'il va falloir rembourser soit le pge
soit commencé à le rembourser l'état les
surplus des trois mois ses 10 ans
pendant dix ans on va devoir pays cela
alors est ce que est ce qu'il faut pas
plutôt une sorte de fonds de solidarité
prise en charge par les assureurs prise
en charge pour partie par par l'état et
peut-être une sorte de mutualisation
entre les restaurateurs qui ont plus de
moyens et puis ceux qui n'y arrivent pas
à jeun pour que au fond ce ne soit pas
des prêts mais ce soit d'une forme de
solidarité donc deux d'argent de dons
quoi il ya il ya ce niveau là et puis
vous avez parlé des loyers nous on a
posé la question tel débat est à nouveau
pardon je veux pas faire du populisme et
la politique et les politiques hommes et
absence ce sujet il y a le code civil et
le code civil vous avez l'article 12 18
du code civil qui est la force majeure
et qui suspend l'ensemble des contrats
et selon l'analyse de nombreux cabinets
d'avocats et bien les baux commerciaux
sont suspendus tous les contrats sont
suspendus dont les baux commerciaux et
nous n'avons pas la réponse du parlement
sur ce sujet puisque le 12 18 10 quoi ça
suspens les loyers donc en d'autres
termes si mon bail se finit dans 36 mois
et bien au lieu de se finir dans 36 mois
il se finit dans 39 ans il se prolonge
de temps cette question là c'est au
parlement d'y répondre mais c'est assez
pour tribunaux systématiquement de
répondre
or on le voit bien dans cette crise que
ce soit sur la question des assurances
que ce soit sur la question des baux
commerciaux et bien les tribunaux
malheureusement vous être engorgé par
ces questions parce que le parlement ne
répond pas à ces questions non à la fois
vous savez je suis assez à l'aise je dis
oui on doit faire de la politique
autrement et on a été élu pour ça et si
on fait pas de la politique autrement on
sera pas réélu
reconnaissez aussi que tout arrive très
vite et qu'il faut aussi regarder au fil
de l'eau ce qui se passe sur son furet
pourtant j'ai 52 ans marié soudan sur
mac ou pas je le fais
dont acte mais est on 02 chiffre
d'affaires de là puisque vous ce que
vous décrivez là je dirais il doit il
doit être regardée par le parlement et
il faudra qu'il soit regardé très vite
oui voilà et donc je pense que dans les
semaines qui viennent là et parce que
c'est une j'espère jours mais j'ai
potence plutôt semaine ce sera étudié au
parlement et ce sera étudiée parce que
je crois vraiment qu'il ya une volonté
mais vraiment une volonté du
gouvernement d'aider les restaurateurs
alors les éditions francis lefebvre ont
déjà tranché sur cette question dès le
slavia travail et santé 17 mars l'aller
mais vous l'avez allez je suis raphaël
legendre du quotidien le point je vous
donne la parole vous lis nous redonner
quelques chiffres je crois sur le coup
le coût économique dans la restauration
est peut-être réagir à feu à se tasser
défend ces échanges
bah oui on voit que le débat économique
est très important autour de ce secteur
et c'est un secteur très importante pour
l'économie française je vous donne
quelques chiffres comme ça le nombre de
restaurants en france cent soixante huit
mille entreprises c'est colossal ça
représente un chiffre d'affaires de près
de 56 milliards d'euros et surtout il
embauche 830 mille salariés
si vous ajoutez à cela les près de 40000
bistrot et café on trouve de partout en
france eh ben c'est près de 900 mille
personnes dont l'emploi est aujourd'hui
menacé
dans ce secteur c'est absolument
colossal ces dix dernières années la
restauration était le plus grand envahir
grand en france l'année dernière
absolument énorme pour le secteur et
pour le pour le gouvernement
alors pour l'instant l'exécutif a promis
de maintenir le chômage partiel à 100%
jusqu'à la fin de septembre ce qui ne
sera pas le cas de toutes les
entreprises puisque le chômage partiel
va réduire
et puis des exonérations de charges
jusqu'à saint jouin mais après après on
sait que l'économie ne repartira pas ici
et donc basse
la question de ces matchs ardus alors
pour redonner peut-être un peu d'espoir
à ceux qui nous écoutent
forcément les clients pas que les
restaurateurs comment ça s'est passé à
l'étranger
certains pays ont rouvert leurs
terrasses leur restaurant avant nous
est-ce que des clients sont revenus
bien sûr alors est ce que les clients
sont revenus pas vraiment par contre on
a des consignes et dès la début mai
suisse en croatie par exemple l'espagne
de l'outré mer le portugal bref ça
repart ça repart un peu partout en
europe
la grande question c'est le retour des
clients et leur département il ya un
écran ya là bas plus de la moitié guide
pour la plupart c'est ce que vous
redoutez le plus
oui alors j'ai juste rap a précisé
quelques chiffres en fait en réalité la
restauration c'est 90 milliards ces 800
et c'est près d'un million d'emplois
mais c'est aussi on fait travailler nos
artisans de la terre et de la mer nos
électeurs aujourd'hui son bord du
gouffre et on n'en parle pas assez
les vignerons on n'a pas vendu de 20
dans nos restaurants parce qu'on vend en
vend du vin aussi alors qu'est ce que
vous dites à ceux qui nous écoutent les
terrasses vont rouvrir ses venez venez
en nombre n'ayez pas peur je crois que
les français et françaises ont envie de
venir
on a envie d accueil on a dit qu'on
rendez vous on est on est un peu timide
sur le sujet donc on n'a pas vraiment
aujourd'hui les moyens de t'accueillir
et pourtant moi j'aimerais vous à voir
ce soir on va malheureusement même sur
les plateaux de télévision ça reste
compliqué il faut toucher mot de la fin
richard faut tout faire pour accueillir
monsieur les maires de tout le village
de france
il faut prêter des ddt à hassi faut
prêter
là où il y avait des voitures on remet
les passages pour qu'ils puissent faire
des terrasses sur le trottoir les
français ont besoin de respirer de
trouver la joie et donc la joie elle
passe toujours par manger et boire
modérément mais manger et boire donc il
faut ré ouvrir pour les restaurateurs et
les français puissent se retrouver
merci beaucoup pour ce message de
vitalité et de convivialité
merci à vous merci à tous les deux
d'être venu sur le plateau d'el cp on va
parler à présent de cette avalanche de
plaintes plainte déposée contre le
gouvernement
je vous le disais pour sa mauvaise
gestion de la crise par toutes sortes
d'associations de syndicats de médecins
de détenus de citoyens alors qu'est ce
que ces recours judiciaires 10 de l'état
de nos démocraties est ce qu'on peut
parler de surenchère pénale autour de ce
qu vide 19
est-ce que c'est dangereux ou pas avant
d'en débattre les faits rien que les
faits avec clément méric et rabih cas il
est le premier à avoir déposé plainte
dès le mois de mars pour le compte de
trois médecins dans le viseur de mettre
division edouard philippe olivier
ferrand et surtout agnès buzyn pour ses
propos du 17 mars dans le monde elle dit
quand j'ai quitté le ministère
je pleurais parce que je savais la vague
du tsunami était devant nous je suis
parti en sachant que les élections
n'auraient pas lieu
donc elle s'appelle maria c'est
exactement problème de fond donc quand
la représentation nationale ne s'indigne
pas face à de tels propos à il faut bien
que le peuple j'ai envie de dire que les
citoyens eux prennent leur honneur pour
cet avocat
ces plaintes sont le symptôme d'un mal
plus profond on peut quand même se
demander pourquoi est ce qu'à un moment
donné 75 plein ont dû être déposée nous
sommes dans une rupture inédite sur le
plan institutionnel de la confiance dans
le gouvernement
regardez ce qui se passe avec johnson
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne
vous avez une population qui
majoritairement malgré les couacs malgré
tout ce qu'on veut et derrière son
gouvernement en france est exactement
inverse
l'amendement pour l'amendement cette
structure de confiance présente aussi
des risques de dérives
le gouvernement met le site plainte
qu'ovide mise en ligne par bruno gaccio
propose de télécharger des dossiers pré
remplie pour faciliter les dépôts de
plaintes man commune et main pour alain
finkielkraut ce phénomène traduit
surtout un état d'esprit bien français
aujourd'hui cet état que l'on contrôle
que l'on surveille et que l'on juge
eh bien on lui demande tout l'exécutif
pour eux est censé tout savoir tout
prévoir et tout pouvoir et donc les
retards deviennent des crimes
l'incertitude est niée et la tragédie
aussi et c'est ce qui fait qu'en effet
le vent mauvais du populisme pénal
souffle sur la france
populisme pénal ou simple besoin de
vérité au dernier décompte on dénombre
75 plainte contre l'exécutif
la plupart portent sur les commandes de
masques de test ou sur le maintien du
premier tour des municipales
neuf d'entre elles viste emmanuel macron
pourtant protégé par l'immunité
présidentielle
côté gouvernement edouard philippe est
le champion toute catégorie
vient ensuite agnès buzyn qui semble
bien déterminé à s'expliquer est ce que
vous avez peur d'un éventuel procès
pénal non non non j'ai ma conscience
pour moi je sais ce que j'ai fait et je
dirais que j'ai hâte de pouvoir parler
devant la commission d' enquête
parlementaire
la commission denquête de l'assemblée ne
devrait pas auditionner agnès buzyn
avant la fin des municipales c'est en
tout cas le souhait de la droite à qui
reviendra le poste de rapporteur
bonsoir arié alimi merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris et vous avez déposé
plusieurs plaintes contre x auprès du
parquet de paris vous allez nous
expliquer tout ça pour différents motifs
pour différentes situations
derrière son écran depuis billon et
j'espère vraiment que ça va marcher
bonsoir maître alain jacubowicz vous
êtes là quel plaisir
vous allez au revoir et c'est assez
inédit dialoguer avec l'un de vos
confrères
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat
également au barreau de lyon et de et de
paris
peut-être je commence avec vous parce
que j'aimerais savoir au fond ce que
vous pensez
c'est de ce nombre de plaintes 75 plein
c'est beaucoup
qu'est ce que ça signifie à votre avis
cette ce nombre important qui pourrait
d'ailleurs augmenté que des citoyens des
associations des syndicats décident soit
devant la cour de justice soit devant le
parquet de paris est bien de demander
des comptes pour tel ou tel sujet à des
ministres à des représentants de l'état
le mans une équipe des ministres des
représentants de l'état c'est le
fonctionnement d'une démocratie et d'un
état de droit
ester en justice est un droit
constitutionnel de la rechercher la
responsabilité pénale et je me permet de
corriger un petit peu votre propos ce ne
sont pas des plaintes qui sont déposées
contre le gouvernement ce sont des
plaintes qui sont déposées contre des
personnes des hommes des femmes et des
êtres humains qui se trouve être
ministre c'est donc une responsabilité
personnelle
henri paul faire la différence entre
deux choses d'abord la responsabilité
gouvernementale qui relève d'une
responsabilité politique et non pas
d'une responsabilité judiciaire
il ya les actes individuels ils peuvent
avoir été commis à l hôtel et relève de
la responsabilité pénale et s'agisse
temps deux ministres de la cour de
justice de la république
en ce qui me concerne je considère qu'il
ya un engouement qui était l'iran que le
le virus du commis de 19 ans a touché la
justice nous sommes dans un une sorte de
juridique au virus qui me paraît pas
sérieux qu'elle a nettement en france
que dans d'autres pays pardonnez moi de
vous interrompre il ya plus de plaintes
en france que dans d'autres pays on
n'est pas les seuls à faire ce genre de
recours en justice
mais il y en a plus qu'est-ce que ça
traduit est ce que vous diriez avec
alain finkielkraut convient d'entendre
qu'il s'agit d'une forme de populisme
pénal
écoutez moi j'aime pas tellement le
terme de populiste qu'on utilise à tous
crins dans tous les sens je crois
qu'effectivement il ya un besoin de
vérité et ce besoin est légitime
le gouvernement doit rendre des comptes
il ya des cadres juridiques de rendre
des comptes il ya des vraies questions à
des vrais problèmes ont ils ne relèvent
pas de la justice pénale parce que les
qualifications pénales qui sont retenus
ne tiennent pas la route ou simplement
et je crois que mes confrères qui ont
déposé ces plaintes le savent
parfaitement alors expéditions et vous
aurez évidemment un droit de réponse
pour quelles raisons ces plaintes ne
sont pas ne peuvent aboutir selon vous
sur le plan strictement pénale et là on
va faire un peu de droit les
qualifications qui sont retenus sont des
qualification de mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui ou de d'abstention
volontaire de non-assistance à personne
en danger
il s'agit de d league volontaires
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que l'on prouve
que volontairement le ministre en
question a attenté à la vie admis en
danger avec l'intention de tuer de nuire
ou d'occasionner des préjudices
c'est tout simplement aberrant ce sont
des délits qui nécessite une intention a
rien de rien n'était après il ya des
délits non intentionnels pu gagner
effectivement l'homicide involontaire ou
l'eau c'est ce qu'on appelle la loi
fauchon dans notre dans notre jargon qui
est selon moi constitution des dossiers
aujourd'hui je ne dis pas ça ne tient
pas absolument pas je dis simplement
qu'à une précipitation une espèce de
course à l'échalote de compétition entre
l association ce sont des plaintes et
pour moi sont des planes politique et
non pas des plaintes juridique je pense
comme au bout du compte tout le monde va
y perdre une décrédibilisation d'une
part pour moi ce sont des plaintes voici
aujourd'hui on vient voir je dis ça ne
tient pas la route et j'y vais pas c'est
très clair et vous avez la parole a
réuni des plaintes politique est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas un peu dans un combat
politique avec tous les ailes tous les
clients que vous défendez qui portent
plainte aujourd'hui plutôt que dans un
combat judiciaire
d'abord le les deux ne s'excluent pas
mais c'est d'abord un pas un combat mais
simplement une action judiciaire
j'ai deux syndicats le collectif
intérieur urgence mais également la cgt
santé qui représentent des médecins des
infirmiers et des infirmières qui sont
soit pour certains sont morts certains
ont été contaminées beaucoup pensent
qu'il ne le serait pas mort vous ne
serez n'aurait pas été contaminés s'il
n'y avait pas eu des fautes qui ont été
commises par des personnes effectivement
on ne sait pas encore lesquels c'est la
raison pour laquelle on dépose des
plaintes contre x
au parquet de paris et non pas le des
plaintes nommément devant la cour de
justice de la république
quels sont les chefs d'inculpation
précisément puisque d'après maître
jacques baud vite
certains de ces chefs là ne sont pas
recevables alors on peut faire du droit
effectivement il ya une infraction qui
n'a pas été évoquée par mon confrère qui
est l'abstention à combattre un sinistre
à partir du moment où on a connaissance
de ce sinistre et lorsqu'on fait les
chronologies de l'apparition de la
maladie des revues scientifiques comme
27 comme ça et sarrians comme comme les
recommandations de l oms notamment en ce
qui concerne le port du masque qui
pendant très longtemps pour ces
personnes dont il est question et bien
n'était pas nécessaire on se rencontre
que les dirigeants des l'administration
peut être la rs peut-être d'autres des
directeurs d'hôpitaux savait
pertinemment que en mettant un masque ou
si il y avait eu des commandes de
masques à un moment donné il n'y aurait
pas eu de contamination et de mort se
sont ré jusqu'au jusqu'où remonter en
fait la chaîne de culpabilité si je dire
depuis culpabilité présumée dans cette
affaire là parce que si si on est dans
le cas d'une épidémie on est dans un
monde incertain
la question des masques remonte on l'a
vu à des gouvernements précédents même
si on peut poser il faut poser cette
question jusqu'où remonte la
responsabilité dans ces cas là face
ensemble avec les kings ça dépend du
type d'infraction par exemple celle qui
vient d'être bloquée mais pas une
infraction non intentionnelle c'est une
attraction intentionnelle c'est à dire
qu'on a connaissance d'un sinistre et on
prend des décisions non pas deux on n'a
pas l'intention de tuer mais on prend
des décisions qui font que on n'empêche
pas ce sinistre pour des raisons
économiques pour des raisons budgétaires
ça c'est pour ça qu'on est bon d accueil
la difficulté sera de le réussir à le
prouver parce qu'il avait eu aussi des
scientifiques qui ont pu se tromper ou
changer d'avis sur la base desquelles
les décisions politiques ont pu être
prise le 24 janvier vous avez l'eau oms
qui dit qu'il faut tester tester tester
le 24 janvier vous avez des revues
scientifiques qui disent qu'il faut
mettre des masques ou tout au moins pour
les personnes contaminées et vous avez
eu une suppression des masques ffp2 et
des masques chirurgicaux sur une longue
période pas uniquement ce gouvernement
mais d'autres décisions antérieures
alors même qu'il y avait des obligations
administratives de les maintenir en
stock
c'est une faute et c'est aussi ce qu'on
appelle pour les délits non
intentionnels une fois
caractérisée qui permet de retenir la
responsabilité pénale en délits non
intentionnels c'est aussi pour ça que je
ne suis pas en accord
vous me demandiez ce que ce sont des
plaintes également politique ça peut
l'être également bien évidemment est ce
que dans un contexte où le revendiquer
c'est gênant sur une équipe pourquoi
parce que si on est dans un contexte
ainsi institutionnelle très particulier
où il n'y a plus du tout de
contre-pouvoir où il ya eu un état
d'exception
pendant très longtemps où la justice est
en berne où le parlement est en berne
également et où il n'ya plus
d'expression démocratique faire le choix
de l'action judiciaire qu'elle soit
civile pénale ou administrative
c'est choisir le démocratie
contrairement à l'expression du
populisme pénal c'est choisir la
résolution pacifique d'une d'un conflit
et non pas la violence dans la rue donc
oui effectivement je considère que ça
une action politique et si une action
bienfaisante et non pas négative ou
populistes que montaient leur maître
alain jakubowicz vous réponds oui en
fait je suis pas en totale opposition
avec ce qui vient d'être dit il ya une
nuance dans le propos de mon confrère
qui mérite d'être souligné c'est que
nous sommes partis sur les plaintes dont
était saisi la cour de justice de la
république
or mon confrère et ami halimi vient
d'apporter une nuance extrêmement
important puisque lui il ne parle pas de
plaintes dont est saisie la cour de
justice de la république mais le parquet
de paris
et en l'espèce le pôle santé du parquet
donc on est là dans une recherche de
responsabilité qui est différente il ne
glisse pas les membres du gouvernement
par ces plaintes il vise x
il vise qui compte pour être identifiés
dans le cadre d'une instruction s'est
singulièrement différent tout à fait ça
évidemment différente et il faut savoir
qu'il ya effectivement actuellement plus
de 70 plaindre je considère
personnellement et subjectivement pas
très sérieuse hiviz ministre et le
premier d'entre eux comme vous le
rappeliez auprès de la cour de justice
de la république qui aura une
instruction autonome et puis il y a
plusieurs dizaines et sans doute une
cinquantaine au moins deux plaintes dont
est saisi le parquet de paris dans un
cadre différent qui est celui qui vient
d'être évoquée par m halimi merci de la
distinction je sais gré à mon confrère
mais ça ne m'étonne pas de lui deux de
revendiquer de reconnaître et de
revendiquer cette cette dimension
politique pourquoi pas c'est pas ma
vision de celle qui vient d'être
ok de porter des dossiers donc des
plaintes devant la cour de justice de la
république contre olivier ferrand agnès
buzyn edouard philippe
non parce que d'abord viser nommément
des personnes je pense que c'est pas
très joli
je pense qu'il revient il incombe aux
juges de déterminer qu'ils se fassent
qui est responsable à l'issue d'une
véritable enquête après avoir fait des
actes des perquisitions après avoir
entendu tout le monde ça c'est la
première chose en plus stratégiquement
je trouve que ça n'aboutira pas dans la
mesure où la cour de justice de la
république est un organe hybride qui est
composé à la fois de parlementaires de
politique qui vont bloquer finalement il
ya aussi des maîtres rude des requêtes
au départ un qui vont bloquer finalement
mon à mon sens le stade de l'enquêté il
n'y aura même pas d' enquête ou de
manifestation de la vérité c'est la
raison pour laquelle stratégiquement
c'était à mon sens pas très utile pour
vous compariez 7 ce qui se passe
monsieur jacques ou jaco vite avec avec
le sang contaminé parce que c'est le
spectre de ceux de ce procès là dont on
se souvient d'ailleurs les 13 qu'il a pu
laisser avec avec l'épidémie de covin et
enfin l' affaire du sang contaminé a
beaucoup marqué on perd notre histoire
judiciaire
d'ailleurs je il ya cette nuance qui
vient de ce procès notamment des propos
qui avaient été tenus par madame
georgina dufoix
à l'époque on s'était beaucoup gaussés
belle pour ses propos et je pense que
l'on avait tort lorsqu'elle avait fait
la différence entre responsables et
coupables la responsabilité une chose
une sorte de responsabilité morale qui
peut être retenu la culpabilité pénale
est une autre chose et je pense que
madame georgie date du froid avait
raison de faire cette distinction à
l'époque entre la responsabilité morale
ou la responsabilité politique et la
culpabilité pénale ce sont deux choses
qui sont très distincts merci doré
d'ailleurs là où nous divergeons avec m
halimi pardon c'est que selon moi cette
requête vérité qui est indispensable il
faut que l'on sache ce qui s'est passé
et s'il ya des responsabilités pour moi
elle relève davantage de la part de
tokai parlementaire absolue disposent
pas des mêmes moyens et qui permettront
de déterminer indique d'ailleurs que
l'on
être père normand terre à l'obligation
beychevelle initiants parquet si des
délits sont identiques je voulais
terminer par cela vous savez que la
commission d' enquête parlementaire à
l'assemblée et au sénat s'est installée
vous avez confiance d'une dune d'un mot
oui ou non dans cette enquête de des
parlementaires oui bien sûr j'ai
confiance qu'avec parlementaire mais ce
n'est pas incompatible avec une
responsabilité pénale s'est dit merci m
halimi d'être venu sur le plateau d'
lcpc lors de la chronique de camille
saféris camille derrière son écran et sa
bibliothèque bonsoir camille l'unique
gagnant qui nous fait partager des
apéros zoom avec les députés alors qui
camille avec qui avez-vous à traquer ce
soir et bien ce soir j'ai trinquer en
vrai pas un zoom g trinquer avec
dominique potier qui est député ps de
meurthe et moselle
nous étions la terrasse du café mais on
dans le 18e arrondissement qui va donc
rouvrir bientôt dans quelques jours mais
qui est encore fermé on a eu le
privilège de pouvoir boire un verre là
alors dominique pottier c'est un magret
culteurs il est très engagé il est
président du pays terre de lorraine il
il aime traire les vaches et aussi aller
à la messe c'est un chrétien qui
s'assume
il a été très heureux m'at-il dit de
retourner à l'assemblée hier en chair et
en os parce que les réunions vidéo en
zoom justement ça commençait à bien
faire et il n'est pas le seul député
dans ce cas avait souvent la barre si
vous savez à 0 supporte plus ah bon ce
matin en commission pour la première
fois c'était en présentiel assez
nombreux et aide à retrouver cette joie
le style de chaka chaka a dit à sa
manière et se taper sur l'épaule à
s'embrasser non non surtout pas surtout
quand même mais dans des actes des
regards puisque on a un débat serait
globalement ya de l'intelligencia du
coeur il ya un profond attachement au
pays à la démocratie et beaucoup
d'humour aussi et d'humour
mon avis on va pas parce qu'on a un
master vous avez raconté des blagues non
pas des blagues mais on sait on a
retrouvé le plaisir d'une castagnade
une petite castagne gentil quand la
controverse le plaisir de la discussion
bien sûr alors qu'est ce que dominique
potier apporte comme produits de la
ferme à ses collègues de l'assemblée
ça c'est une vraie question est qui
vénère alors ils apportent du saucisson
lorrain cedus et du fromage de tête des
fromages des vins et surtout et surtout
de la mirabelle de lorraine bien sûr
est-ce quelque chose qui en politique
est aussi puissant que l'évocation la
force tellurique poétique de l'eau de
vie de mirabelle
non mais elle peut faire prendre des
décisions bon c'est bon bon café sachets
à saïx ses potions magiques et vous en
apporter l'assemblée c'est une façon de
partager de façon exceptionnelle
c'est une bouteille peut faire trois ans
mais symboliquement j'ai toujours ce
produit qui est issu des vergers et
transformé par nous mêmes chacun aime
témoigner à l'assemblée de ce qu'il est
profondément
alors depuis le début de cette rencontre
dominique petit me faisait penser à
quelqu'un et même à plusieurs personnes
différentes et à mélanger puis
finalement j'ai eu une illumination j'ai
trouvé il ya du bourvil un peu chez vous
on vous l'a jamais dit une fois sur le
sort est vrai ayez du spock un peu aa
c'est c'est eh ben
alors il ya une autre élément c'est
cette terrible c'est françois ruffin qui
me l'a fait il dit dominique je les aime
beaucoup il est un peu comme maître yoda
il dit il fait penser à mettre yoda une
forme de sagesse on les écoute bon et
moi je me rends gorgée et je sai paix
qui est maître yoda j'avais pas relu mes
et il me montre la photo ap le gall et
fils recherches allaient me montrait
maître yoda depuis jeu et françois
ruffin excellent excellent j'adore de
quelque chose absolument rien quelque
chose merci merci beaucoup
camille et revenez nous vite en chair et
en os enfin zir on va parler à présent
d'un homme l'assemblée ne sera plus là
la même sans lui il y as et j'ai siégé
pendant des années il avait un franc
parler c'était un bretteur c'était aussi
un fin tacticien un passionné surtout
par sa ville paris et puis sa famille
politique et est souvent venu sur ce
plateau et c'était toujours un plaisir
de l'écouter au revoir monsieur claude
goasguen thomas des pré revient pour
nous sur son parcours et les réactions
après l'annoncé de sa disparition
williams 25 ans à l'assemblée nationale
un quart de siècle claude goasguen
c'était un député que l'on n'oublie pas
[Musique]
cette salle des quatre colonnes claude
goasguen la connaît c'est bien comme sa
poche même devenu député en 1993 d'abord
suppléant
avant d'être élue à paris il est resté
ici pendant presque 25 ans sans
discontinuer
il avait un caractère bien trempé
chiraquien ses positions étaient parfois
très clivante et dans l'hémicycle claude
goasguen
ça donnait ça c'est la première fois
qu'un ministre du budget nommé
régulièrement par un gouvernement
fraudent le fisc alors qu'il est chargé
de réaliser la france vise la parole des
clash comme celui ci ses collègues
pourrait en raconter des dizaines depuis
ce matin les hommages se multiplient à
commencer par ses amis de droite
bonjour gilles carez bonjour vous vous
connaissez bien claude goasguen vous
étiez même son voisin dans l'hémicycle
acteullement il avions été élu ensemble
en 1993 souvenir marquant pour moi c'est
lorsque claude demandant parole lève la
main s'empare du micro et puis exprime
ses opinions avec force et conviction
brigitte kuster quelle image
garderez-vous de claude goasguen
quelqu'un de profondément attachant
c'est une grande figure parisienne qui
vient de nous quitter et c'est pas un
vain mot que de le dire il va manquer à
l'ags nationale tant que collègues
députés
sommes nous étions amis nommer le député
à leers
sur twitter les réactions viennent de
tous les bords politiques nicolas
sarkozy parle d'un élu qui manquera
françois bayrou pleure un ami qu'importe
ce que la politique peut dire et de son
côté le président de l'assemblée richard
ferrand éprouve une grande tristesse
bonjour bernard accoyer bonjour qu'est
ce que vous retiendrez lui il ya
toujours dans les groupes
le mans terre des voix dominante et si
on peut dire qu'une voix dominante
existait c'était celle de vienne enrayer
un groupe et l'un portait souvent les
décisions lorsque je présidais le groupe
et qu'il n'étions pas d'accord je
redoutais c'est l'intervention parce que
je savais qu'il allait convaincre
d'adopter la maison et puis claude
goasguen c'était une histoire politique
particulière ici à l'assemblée à paris
au conseil de paris ou à la mairie du
xvième qu'il a dû abandonner pour garder
son siège de député son histoire
politique qu'il a débuté à la droite de
la droite avec ses amis alain madelin
gérard longuet ou encore patrick
devedjan ben il a milité pour l'algérie
française
et puis également pour un candidat
d'extrême droite jean louis tixier
vignancour lors de la présidentielle de
un engagement qu'il qualifiait d' erreur
de jeunesse mais que manuel valls ne
manquait pas de lui rappeler en 2014
monsieur goasguen vous en venez vous de
l'extrême droite vous savez ce qu'il en
est nous nous sommes complaisant avec
personne
vous êtes complaisant et nous nous
créions et chaussants clair avec nous
des propos qui avaient suscité un tollé
chez les députés les républicains qui
avaient quitté l'hémicycle
et puis claude goasguen c'était aussi un
habitué des plateaux dès le cp il était
beaucoup venus dans nos émissions depuis
20 ans avec ses propos clivant sa
culture est aussi son sens de l'humour
quels seront vos opinions politiques
chez duhamel alors j'ai des opinions
politiques mais dès qu'elle voit l'ami m
claude goasguen c'était tout ça à la
fois il est décédé à 75 ans des suites
du corona virus ici à l'assemblée
nationale qu'on les aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas il aura marqué les esprits
merci thomas et on a aussi évidemment
une pensée ce soir pour guy bedos guy
bedos qui s'en va lui aussi
décidément immense guy bedos magicien
des mots et du culot ont permis comme
chaque soir avec le jour d'après ce soir
c'est eric rochant le réalisateur et
showrunner du bureau des légendes de
canal+ qui nous parle du cinéma après le
corona
[Musique]
[Rires]
il est mort non je souhaiterais que vous
inquiétiez sur votre ancien patron
qu'est ce qu'on cherchait
notre en existence d'une taupe il a peur
d'avoir été balancé ça
bonjour eric rochant bonjour et merci de
nous accorder cet entretien à distance
alors ce premier mois de confinement il
a été très particulier pour vous puisque
vous étiez en salle de montage pour
terminer la nouvelle saison du bureau
des légendes c'est un contexte
particulier puisqu'en même temps les
téléspectateurs trépigner d'impatience
de découvrir enfin cette série alors
qu'ils étaient reclus chez the vous
l'avez vécu comment cette première
période
d'abord avec angoisse parce
qu'effectivement bon angoisse était qu'
on ne puisse pas livrer de l'eau de
légende en fait travaillé 18 mois pour
le derniers mètres de la course se voir
arrêter
j'avais vraiment peur qu'on ne puisse
pas livrés et que finalement voilà qu'il
faille repousser la diffusion très loin
derrière en septembre octobre donc ça ça
c'était très angoissant
une fois qu'on a vu que finalement on
pouvait se débrouiller s'organiser pour
pour terminer quand même à distance tout
ce qu'ils avaient à faire
j'ai été un peu rassurés on a quand même
l'impression d'être un peu dans un film
où le réel a fait plus fort que tout ce
qui a été fait en matière de cinéma /
sur les épidémies
je raisonne pas je réagis pas je ressens
pas les choses comme ça je me dis pas
rôdés comme dans un film
enfin oui on est content j'ai vu plein
de films je vous ai pitié mais il est
plein de chips ou de catastrophes
naturelles
car en fait on vit une catastrophe
naturelle on perd des gens même très
proche de nous chacun de nous on perd
des gens pas seulement nos anciens mais
aussi aussi à des gens jeunes
l'ingénieur du son mark and games qui a
été avec nous sur le tournage du bureau
des légendes pendant quatre mois cinq
mois cet été alors voilà on était
ensemble cet été en fête a été touché
par le crâne à virus à l'âge de 54 ans
des d'ailleurs voilà et donc on a été
extrêmement triste ça a été ça a été un
coup de bambou pour tous les gens qui me
connaissent et pour toute l'équipe mais
ça a montré aussi que voilà qu' il
fallait vraiment faire attention
vraiment rester chez soi qu'est ce que
le cinéaste regarde en ce moment il ya
que y'a que de la place pour l'homme ou
déjà vous vous observez le réel avec un
regarde
d'artistes alors bizarrement je sais pas
si ces cinéastes qui regardent pas de
vêtements le citoyen où l'être humain la
détente la planète
je je je je comprends mieux et je pense
que tous les tous les étudiants et tous
les jeunes qui est ce qu'ils vont au
lycée aujourd'hui doivent profiter de
cet instant pour mieux comprendre ce
qu'on leur a raconté sur les événements
sur la guerre l'occupation c'est la
grande catastrophe n'était pas seul à
turenne celle là qui a finalement ce qui
s'est abattue sur nos parents et nos
grands parents je pense que là c'est
l'histoire contemporaine évidemment mais
ça nous permet de comprendre un peu les
lignes de force les réactions la
bassesse des uns et la grandeur des
autres ce qu'ils peuvent ceux qui
trouvent la force en eux de 2 voilà moi
c'est ça que je vois en fait c'est une
sorte d'éclairage aujourd'hui parce
qu'on le vit à part même niveau non plus
hein c'est pas c'est pas la seconde
guerre mondiale mais parce qu'on vit
quelque chose de fort qui nous concerne
tous et qui est assez dangereux et
angoissant et bien je vois un peu les
réactions de chacun et finalement je
retrouve des choses que j'ai vues dans
des fibres sur l'occupation presque mais
quelle par exemple c'est par ici par
exemple je pense évidemment à d'autres
où on a vu des gens faire des compromis
trouvé des moyens et en fait on retrouve
à peu près tout les tous les
comportements tout et tous les
sentiments qu'on pouvait donc on peut
mieux comprendre en fait ce qui se passe
ce qui s'est passé à l'époque
en fait rien ne change vous avez envie
d'en faire quelque chose ou c'est trop
tôt il faut il faudra mettre des images
des mots il faudra de la fiction pour
raconter alors qu'il nous est arrivé
aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
auteurs tous les artistes tous les
écrivains et tous les romanciers
écrivent sur la situation qui sont en
train de vie roues sur la situation qui
va qui va arriver je pense que je sais
pas ce que je vais faire car le marché
va être saturé de fiction qui tiennent
qui qui qui qui je passe des histoires
d'amour formidable des comédies
romantiques mais on sent une pointe de
six lits
entre deux voisins qui sont trop trop de
films sur le confinement pas nous
condamner à la médiocrité
donc parce que j'ai des poètes le pot
est resteront les poètes c'est à dire
ils vont trouver leur poésie va se
nourrir de cette nouvelle situation
qu'est le confinement alors de strauss
soit l'enfer c'est les autres soient des
comédies romantiques
il va y avoir un serial killer on va
trouver un serial killer qui commence à
tuer tout le monde dans un building où
tout le monde est confiné passera très
intéressant d'ailleurs je donne
gratuitement l'idée à celui qui veulent
écrire
enfin bref en tous les cas il va y avoir
beaucoup de choses en ce qui me concerne
moi je fais un tout petit peu quand même
hein sorte de pas de cinéma du réel mais
je m'inspire je place mes histoires dans
le réel mais dans la réalité c'est pour
ça que je fais d'ailleurs le bureau des
gens c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
beaucoup mieux c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait des patriotes j'aime bien raconter
des histoires qui parlent du monde
d'aujourd'hui et qui soit quand même un
peu des ombres divertissante
c'est pour ça que je fais aussi des
films d'espionnage c'est une sorte de
faire des films de suspense et tous en
même temps mais donc la difficulté ça va
être en difficulté et aussi la nécessité
d'inscrire nos histoires dans le monde
qui aura connu le coronavirus kir a
connu sept 7
cette épidémie est donc il va falloir il
s'agit pas de faire d'anticipation dans
tous les cas il va falloir en tenir
compte à leur en tenir compte soit en
plaçant nos histoires dans l'épidémie
pendant l'épidémie soit emplacement
forcément en racontant l'épidémie elle
même c'est ça je crois pas aujourd'hui
il ya que ça raconte pas grand-chose à
ragots des doutes que qu'une épidémie
howey on voit des journaux d'actualité
on parle de absolument rien d'autre mais
quand on va sortir de là haut quand même
qu'on commence aujourd'hui même moi même
à écrire commencé à écrire et à
concevoir des histoires qui il faudra
développer plus tard on va te ça va être
ça va être inscrit dans ce monde là est
ce monde là on ne sait pas trop bien ce
à quoi il ressemble mais ça va être le
monde qui aura connu ce coronavirus
alors vous en faites pas il y aura des
invariants c'est un peu ce qui peut nous
tous nous rassurer des intermédiaires il
ya des invariants des choses qui vont
rester telle qu'en elle-même et qu'on va
retrouver même
peut-être exaspère exacerbé ou peut-être
émoussés faudrait qu'on en termine avec
à nouveau le cinéma qui va pas bien
forcément temps d'épidémie puisque les
salles ne vont pas ouvrir avant de longs
mois et pas simplement en france le
cinéaste
il pleure aujourd'hui alors en fait il
est triste non non je ne suis pas triste
pour elle évidemment c'est triste tout
ça aide tous les tournages tous les
tournages ce n'est pas une seule
personne qui tourne souffle nous avec
votre petit téléphone et notre caméra
chez soi ce qui se passe c'est que
l'industrie du cinéma va repartir à bloc
et surtout c'est que ceux qui gagnent de
l'argent aujourd'hui dire il ya des gens
qui gagnent alors on est tous à beaucoup
perdre d'argent mais des gens qui
gagnent et ceux qui gagnent de l'argent
ce sont les plateformes se sont tous et
toute l'économie de l'abonnement toute
l'économie numérique tous les toute
l'économie de la distance et donc croyez
moi que les plateformes et je pense que
du coup les du coup les sociétés de
production des plateformes vont avoir
beaucoup d'argent à investir et
énormément ça va être massif
ils vont avoir besoin ils ont de
l'argent là il amasse de l'argent et
donc comme les tournages sont arrêtés
ils vont se retrouver sans rien et donc
il va falloir alimenter cette industrie
là et donc c'est vrai que je ne suis pas
tellement triste pour en tout cas de
l'industrie de la création
cinématographique car elle va repartir
et elle va repartir plus gros qu'avant
encore une fois je le devin et je peux
complètement me planter je pense que
pour les créateurs non c'est une pause
et encore nous laisser des scénaristes
parce que je suis aussi scénariste
bon ben on a l'habitude d'être enfermé
chez soi pour écrire on réalise quand
même que on écrit bien a enfermé chez
soi mais surtout qu'on peut sortir
on sent bien que la création va stimuler
il ya déjà plein de choses sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya des vidéos il ya
des parodies il ya des gentils qui se
filment en s'ennuyant qu'est ce que vous
en pensez ça c'est c'est stimulant
c'est amusant ou c'est totalement
narcissique les deux je pense qu'il ya
de la poésie partout moi je fais des
gens qui expriment une très grande
poésie dans avec n'importe quoi avec des
émoticônes j'attends les émoticônes avec
les vasques
j'attends ce qu'ils vont les inventer
mais la création se niche partout ça
c'est mon côté optimiste là quoi qu'il
arrive la création s'insinue com com
comme l'humidité s'insinue dans
n'importe quelle machine qui serait
boulonné à mort c'est de la chair et du
sang
ça ça vient ça rentre donc tout ça moi
je la création ne s'arrêtera jamais et
elle trouve toujours le moyen de
s'exprimer
justement vous parle des petits des
petites vidéos et aux lyonnais moi je
suis pas très friand de ce genre de
choses mais là tu joues une deux qui
sont très drôle et très inventive donc
voilà non mais je fus pteris pour la
création de jours merci beaucoup c'est
passionnant et revenez nous vite sur sur
les écrans quels qu'ils soient
ça m'a dit merci au revoir l'éternel
optimiste eric rochant c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis et à demain
[Musique]